what do you think about the certainty
that people in the bitcoin maximalist
community
have about this particular piece of
technology bitcoin
is there something interesting they you
think that you might want to say
about this community or is it just is
what it is
i think at the end of the day results
speak for themselves and bitcoin
has had an amazing impact on our
industry
and had has had an amazing impact on the
world
and i think you know the result is still
that bitcoin is very widely adopted
and driving um the adoption of our
industry in many ways
so i think it's very difficult for
people to say that you know bitcoin
maximalists
don't have something that they can latch
on to and say hey there's something very
real here
i i think there's been decisions made by
the bitcoin community and the people who
made the bitcoin protocol
to focus it on bitcoin and to focus in
on
the kind of storing of the ledger of
bitcoin and the information about
bitcoin and the transaction of bitcoin
and to focus on securing that
and i you know i understand why that
decision was made to a certain degree
right it was
about focus it is it was about getting
something worthwhile right
without adding additional features and
additional risk
and you know that decision is is a
decision that was made and has
kind of the benefits of focus and the
benefits of
um a certain amount of security and a
certain amount of
guarantees around uh bitcoin and and
what that is and
and the the value of that and then it
has certain
um limitations you know as a consequence
of
of of doing less or having the system
hold data that isn't related to bitcoin
or not having the system
hold contracts uh contractual outcomes
or smart contract code
so i i think it's just kind of a
decision right and and i i understand
why they're excited and i'm very excited
i started in this industry going to
bitcoin meetups
and i met a lot of fantastic people
libertarian
people that wanted to see the world work
differently and share
a lot of my beliefs and a lot of my
points of view and so
you know anyone who's been in the
industry as long as i have
um has had to come from the bitcoin
ecosystem by virtue of
kind of starting out that early so i
have an unbelievable amount of respect
and admiration and gratitude for
for bitcoin and that it exists and
everything that it's done and that it
birthed this industry there's absolutely
no doubt about that
you know at the same time whatever
design decisions people make
are the design decisions they make right
and so they if you've made a design
decision that this
ledger and this thing will be about
bitcoin it won't be about colored coins
it won't be about op return at 80 bytes
it won't be about these other
kind of nuances that you don't want this
to be about
then that's fine that's that's fine and
that's that's that's a logical decision
that's
and it's called focus and focus has a
lot of value
and a lot of great technology products
have
focused on something and and done that
and then there's a lot of smart people
around bitcoin
building um kind of additional systems
that anchor their security within
bitcoin
and i think that's an interesting
approach that could that could bear
fruit
i think it'll eventually require an
interaction with a bitcoin protocol
in more advanced ways and then there
will be another question of
you know what is the design decision for
bitcoin
is it that bitcoin will be just about
the bitcoin ledger
or does bitcoin want to evolve into
um you know an anchor for all these
other
other systems and and maybe create
additional
data store you know kind of more data on
chain
on the bitcoin blockchain related to
that so i
i'm excited to see how that evolves but
un until then
kind of results speak for themselves and
the results that bitcoin has achieved
for our industry and for
itself as you know kind of the dominant
cryptocurrency and
and the conception of our industry that
people interact with first
is obviously very important and
something that
um i think really everybody in our
industry is grateful for right because
without bitcoin
where where where would our industry be
and that's obviously something that we
we can't forget
you